One common way of giving a cartoon like appearance to a surface is to give it
two or more shades of the same color. For example, in this drawing the sheep's
wool has just two tones, light and dark. You're going to do the same sort of
thing with the diffuse shader we just described. The idea is to modify the
diffuse component. In the diffuse shader code we computed this value by taking
the dot product of the normal and the light. Instead of using the diffuse
component for the shade, we really want to identify two zones. Light and dark.
If the normal is pointing some fair bit towards the light, consider the area
lit. Otherwise, it's dark. Take this sphere as an example. Normally we clamp
the diffuse term at zero and not let it go negative. Above zero and the light
has greater and greater contribution as the dot product increases. This is
realistic, but we can do whatever we want in the shader. One idea to get a two
tone effect is define a critical angle, essentially a dot product value. Below
this value will make the surface uniformly dark, otherwise it's fully lit.